question what is the maximum number of
days as a traveler that he can stay in a
given City continuously and be Exempted
from his fast for instance he goes on to
say um if he's a student he's giving the
game away here if he's a student and
he's traveled abroad for two months is
he Exempted from his fast in Ramadan
most of the scholars what they say that
what is ruling for Salah when a person
travels as Hadith accorded earlier that
a beloved Prophet mam said mentioned
in
MA Hadith number 1667 that a belov
prophet says that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has
Exempted a person from fasting and half
of this prayers when he's traveling and
Exempted a woman from fasting when she's
pregnant Etc
so the ruling what is there for Salah as
a traveler it is the same as for a
person who's fasting and most of the fuk
most of the scholars who the difference
opinion but as for Salah they say that
maximum person can stay in a city in one
place after he has left his own Hometown
is for 4 days so most of the scholars
they agree that same thing is for
fasting that maximum they can stay in a
city and can be considered as a traveler
if for 4 days if they extend then they
will not be considered as a traveler
though there difference opinion in
different schools of thought but the
majority consider this coming to the
second part of the question that if a
person goes for studies and stays in a
foreign land maybe for 2 months or 3
months or several months together will
he be considered as a traveler no in
this condition he's staying for a long
time for months together as far as
fasting is concerned he will have to
fast all the obligatory fast of the
month of Ramadan next question if a
fasting person is fasting the whole day
decides to travel in the afternoon he
starts his travel in the afternoon is it
compulsory on him to break his fast or
is it optional what is the best solution
for him if a person starts the travel
midday or in the afternoon and if he's
in the hometown till afternoon it
becomes f for him to keep the fast at
least at that time only time a traveler
is permitted to break the fast is when
he leaves the hometown
if he decides that he's going to leave
in the afternoon it's not possible that
he does not fast in the morning he has
to fast in the morning because they can
be change of plans if he decide in the
afternoon he may change his plan so then
it will be a sin on him so if a person
is traveling the only time he can break
the fast is when he leave the city
limits until he hasn't left he should
not break so if he leave the city limits
in the afternoon he's permitted to break
not that he should break but if he feels
there's no hardship he can continue
fasting and complete is fast it's
optional on him okay
excellent next question is from one of
our viewers who's a pilot and he
consided himself to be in a Perpetual
state of travel every day he's traveling
on the plane um long
distances and um he's asking is he
Exempted therefore from all fasts if a
person's profession is such that he's a
pilot or if he's a sailor and he has to
travel and if he leaves his hometown and
if he's gone away so but naturally he's
considered the travel he's Exempted from
fasting but he has to make up his
fast before the next of Ramadan so if he
travels a lot then you have to fast in
the holidays mhm whatever holidays he
gets and when he station in home term so
if he does not want to fast he's
Exempted because considered as a
traveler but he'll have to make up the
fast as soon as possible before the next
from
unless you start on a very long flight
maybe from India to New York which is
more than 12 hours but if the the flight
is a short flight I don't think so
there'll be problem